[Applaudissements]
ch ch
ou m'énerve ça fait un an qu'on se le
tape la peut
plus prétentieux quel prétentieux mais
pour qui se prend cet
Espagnol jamais bonjour mais qu'est-ce
qu'il en croit
celui- je sais pas moi je suis stripti
veê de l'établissement c'est vrai vous
pouvez demander à Monsieur BR c'est ma
deè saison AC la monfand je m'en crois
pas demander au autres fiches c'est très
simple regardez regardezle c'est
suffffisant
prétentieux mais qu'est-ce qu' s'en
croit pas ces
Espagnols vaniteux pas orgueilleux par
que l'orgueil c'est non l'allemand est
orgueilleux mais l'Espagnol il est
vanux
ch
ch ça moi aussi je le fais je fais chez
moi ça tout le monde je connais même un
type qu' fait mieux que lui un
suédois
[Musique]
alors c'est long c'est long c'est vrai
ça va 2 minutes on a de la lecture mais
alors
là il devrait saluer après les machin il
a pas le sens de l'ellipse çaieur BR me
dit toujours toi pour toias le sens de
l'ellipse mais lui je le conis je vous
préviens par malheur il y en a TR qui
applaudissent alors là on l'arrête plus
il fait la fermeture il faut lui laisser
la
clé
[Musique]
chiquyou tu m'énerves chquy chiquy
chiquy regardez le C
énergumain et je te cabotti mais je te
cab l'autre soir vous savez pas il a
cassé son talon évidemment il tape
dessus comme un fou et vous croyez qu'il
serait démonté ce TR je t'en fiche il a
fait comme si de rien était il est resté
sur la piste il a terminé en chaussette
ça voulait plus rien dire il était la
risée de toute la clientèle mais il a
pas bougé hein on aurait dit qu'il nous
nargit vous
savez il sont tellement
fiers mais de quoi qu'ils sont si fiers
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont pour
eux des gens qui sont même pas
français le corizon j'en ai mangé une
fois ça m'a donné des rougeur j'avais la
figure com l' foutu et alors la corida
bon il y a pas de
quoi nous quand on tue un BF on n fait
pas un
plat et je me TR je me c'est comme le C
d'OB ça doit être un beau prétentieux
celui-là aussi ça du S plein les mains
ça dit pas
bonjourassin c'est bien la même bande
tout
ça pinoch COD les potkin
assassin il peuvent se garder leur
bonjour
assassin il alle de faire la saleté chez
[Applaudissements]
eux